hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
instructive game to share with you from
the 2023 St Louis rapid in Blitz event
this is a rapid game between Fabiano
Carana on the white end and Ali rea
fua the game kicks off with a Ry Lopez
Berlin defense a near perfect game ahead
here by fuia with this Speedy time
control 25 minutes 10-second increment
it only adds an exclamation point to
this near perfect
game we continue with the ultra solid
D3 preventing any Knight takes E4 lines
avoiding the familiar famous uh Berlin
endgame the main in Balance we see is
the bishop for Knight exchange black
works with the bishop pair in the game
we continue with
H3 E5 is poison defended
indirectly Knight takes e is losing to
Queen D4 familiar double
attack so it is H3 preventing a pin now
the E Pawn is defended directly Knight
C3 and where else for the light Square
Bishop if you go to E6 that would hang
the E pawn queen E2 Queen side castles
not the most common side to Castle on
why is it more appealing here well
there's already half open file for black
and The Rook is on it Bishop B3 black
preserves the bishop pair says my a pawn
is poison is that really true it is in
the game A3 is played if you take the a
pawn B6 King B7 good by
Bishop so here we go A3 King B8 and in
the game it's Knight D2 one of the top
moves in this position is Knight D2
another top move is to Castle Queen side
bring it to a same sides Castle's
position this is not what we experience
in this game we're going to see an
opposite Sid's Castle's position where
this H3 Pawn is a great
liability black will find it much easier
to crack open a file towards the white
king in large part because of this
Pawn now do know white can Castle Queen
side here without fear of a sacrifice on
A3 if black goes in for this why is it
not working well this Fork can be met
with King D2 defending the
Knight all right in this game it is
Knight
D2 Bishop E6 watches out over a couple
of the Knight
jumps and in this game we have
B4 so when B4 is played
in almost all cases um we could safely
assume that the white king is going to
Castle
kingside um but surprisingly enough
there are variations where white can
still
Castle
queenside now they normally don't go
hand inand B4 and queenside castles but
I will be
highlighting uh A variation where that
is still possible and
preferable um again this is going to be
a great liability for the white king
once castled on the king's
side White's attempt in this game is to
try and crack open a file towards the
black king so we have G6 black is now
taking steps to get the Knight into F4
G6 supports that knight
jump from here it's Rook B1 so clearly
there's no queenside castles as a
possibility now this is where the
computer says you could still Castle
queenside oddly enough with B4 in there
what does this look like here's the
suggestion Knight C4 take out the Knight
there's a threat to trap the bishop make
some room and then it says hang a
right again not very common to play in
this way but again it does not want to
bring it to an opposite side's Castle's
position
in this game we have Rook
B1 Knight
H5 kingside castles and it's a race
who's going to be able to crack open a
file first activate the
Rooks F6 top move this is one of many
top moves by
fua uh this is Paving the way for Queen
F7 to defend the Knight which enables G5
and then Knight F4
if captured you could consider taking
with the G Pawn now and there's an open
G file to work with a really nice
maneuver here this
F6 Rook on F to
D1 Queen
F7
F3 and the Knight hops in right away so
I found this a little bit interesting
why uh one more move was not maybe
played
first like G5 and then hop in here
preparing to take towards the center and
get that g file uh why is black maybe
drawn to hopping in straight away once
F3 is in I think in a way black may be
saying you know what now that you've
weakened this Square here if you go
ahead and take my knight now I do have
this Square to work with maybe there's
possibilities to maneuver a bishop into
this weak Square
and still there are ways to crack open a
file on the king side G4 is still going
to be there Landing a fork now that F3
is in so you could still capture in
either Direction with the E Pawn or
maybe the G Pawn in this game he hops in
straight
away Queen F2 there's pressure on the
pawn defended with
B6 and now A4 so white has something to
bite at but again it's a race Here Comes
G5 A5 let me throw a pop quiz your way
how would you respond to this last move
feel free to pause the
video okay fua ignores it he continues
with his own Advance
H5 the sacrifice on this square is not
working so if white chops away like this
you have the queen sliding over to
defend so very resourceful move
here in this game it's Bishop takes
Knight and now we have Pawn on E takes
so initially this uh kind of juked me I
wasn't prepared to see this particular
capture I just figured you take towards
the center get that open G file but in a
way I guess black maybe says I'm going
to still get a file opened G4 is going
to hit the g file will be peeled open
one or more files will be peeled
open and uh I'm going to be trading
additional pawns and that's in general
good news for the side with the bishop
pair so while the file doesn't open up
straight away when it does open it's
going to be that much more
effective in this one we have
D4 black is there
first G4 met with
H4 the G file is going to open up let's
get to the G file takes on
B6 Queen F1 this is not anything
serious black is already there first
taking on F3 Knight takes
F3 uh if you tried to sneak in ignoring
Black's play here Queen A6 there's Rook
takes pawn and if you really wanted to
scare the queen away you could withdraw
the bishop but yeah Queen A6 is far from
working here maybe if the Rook was
already on the a file but not the case
in this one it is the recapture on F3
and now active defense against any Queen
A6 a nice forward move Bishop
C4 H the the queen queen goes to E1 Rook
G3 I mean just look at the Rook
positions here 27 moves
in barreling down against the white king
and these guys are staring at White
pawns the knights are on their favorite
squares but this is all about Rook Play
From Here completely crushing position
now for team
black king H1 out of the pin there was a
threat to take the Knight Queen
D7 now if white in this position let's
say played Rook A1 what move would you
play here feel free to pause the
video okay there's a nice tactic that
black is setting up by moving the queen
to
D7 and that is the sacrifice on
G2 Rook takes Rook Queen H3 leads to
mate if you don't play Rook h
2 Queen takes on G2 is mate and if you
do play here it's just going to be mate
one move
later like that so that's not a good
idea King H2 defends against uh possible
Queen H3 moves once this Pawn is
removed interestingly enough you could
still there's many ways to approach this
position it says you could still smash
through on G2 a couple times and then
sweep in with the queen taking the
Knight
next okay in this one though we have
simply Rook takes Knight Pawn takes Rook
Rook G3 threatening mate the King goes
back to the corner allowing The Rook to
cover the
check but now the F Pawn Falls in both
uh there was one too many threats the
Knight is hit there's also the idea to
still sweep into H3 or even land a fork
if white tried Knight E2 here we could
have the check another check and Rook
H3 game over here for team white what's
tried Rook H2 covers the check but black
still has the Rook F1 move winning the
queen so that's what we have this one if
it's a longer game it would probably
already be uh White would probably have
already thrown in the towel at this
stage here after F3 but at this moment
they're both under a minute so I believe
many of these uh the remainder of this
game is just uh played on out of
momentum completely winning for black F3
threatens The Rook if you move the Rook
the queen would sweep into H3
so white shuts down this diagonal Pawn
takes Knight E4 we get into a rook
versus or excuse me a queen versus two
Rooks position it's a queen and three
pawns versus the two Rooks and soon it's
going to be a queen and four pawns
completely winning there's only one
sensitive point on black side
C7 even if white directs both Rooks
there the queen can easily defend along
this diagonal
no problems here for team black so let's
get these final moves in here nice and
cozy no checks with the King on B7 and
the plan is just March this only past
pawn and there's no stopping it at this
Stage White simply throws in the
towel soon enough this Pawn is going to
cost white one of these Rooks completely
winning position for fu
who played with a
99%
accuracy what' you think of this
one anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below I hope you enjoyed
it and maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care
bye